we do have a lot of people the phones
are just blowing up guys I mean it is
crazy the calls are coming in faster
than we can handle them who's next on
the phone name in town hi my name is
Dakota Coates
I'm from Chesterfield Virginia Dakota
Coates that I like that name that's your
real name yes that is my real name all
right what's on your mind
so uh and this comes from like I I saw a
lot of these I'm pretty liberal I'm what
do they like to call a deflated Bernie
bro okay and really wasn't like that too
enthusiastic about Hillary Clinton I
still voted for anyway sure um and I saw
all of these uh all right I'm air
quotations here all right
like personalities via like Facebook and
Twitter and you know adding to the whole
like I'm in my own bubble thing yeah but
I'm trying to reach across the aisle and
see the other viewpoints and there's
this guy Sam Hyde who has a TV show on
Adult Swim called MD he presents world
peace and he's made a lot of videos like
just kind of rattling up these like sjw
types or whatever you want to call them
okay but he made a good point about how
if you take the electoral college away
you kinda are like taking boys away from
like those flyover States in the States
with low population and I think that
like if you went to anybody in like
let's say New York City or very
liberally like very liberal cities right
you and you ask them like could I wave a
wand and get rid of these backwards
ideas that most these people and the
flyover States have or whatever you want
to call them and most those people will
say yeah you know we want to move
forward we want to be progressive you
know people in those cities but like
you're not giving voice to those who
like live in these like you know low
population areas and like rural rural
areas let's break this down let's break
this down piece by piece okay what does
it mean to give voice everybody gets one
vote right yeah okay and if you're in a
state right now whether it's a very
liberal state or a very conservative
state and you vote in the presidential
election in the opposite way as the
state ultimately votes is your vote
represented at all in the electoral math
of who is elected president
see that's let's see that's the question
that I have is like I don't particularly
know if that like because we don't have
a popular vote so like if you where have
those very very high population density
Ria's like cities and stuff like that I
feel like you know if you had a popular
vote all those votes would go towards
like a Democratic presidential nominee
or representative and all of the rural
votes together would go to tend to more
conservative candidates right yeah but
everybody's vote would count like no
matter what the results of your state
are your vote counts as one point in the
ultimate election results with a pot
national popular vote right yeah and if
right now if in Massachusetts you voted
for Donald Trump your vote counted as
zero in the election results right
regardless of that one vote Trump was
still going to get the twelve or
whatever ellaktor or Hillary was going
to get the twelve electoral vote so you
essentially had no voice as a
conservative in Massachusetts with our
current system yeah yeah so everybody
gets a voice with a national popular
vote
you might be changed what you're getting
to is you might be changing where
candidates are spending more time
instead of arbitrarily strategically
important states like New Hampshire and
Iowa and Nevada they might spend more
time where there are more people but
we've got the internet and TV now right
it's not like before when the electoral
vote was created where if you're can
that it doesn't show up where you are
physically you might have a newspaper
article and otherwise you'd have no idea
what they're about so I don't think
that's really an issue anymore okay
thank you so much really really
appreciate it